The Prieto distribution,
it looks like this.
It doesn't look like a normal distribution.
A lot of you guys had been told about not normal distributions and how many
things follow a normal distribution.
Most things,
but that's really a limited case.
You can understand a Prieto distribution.
If you,
you've all played monopoly,
I presume at the beginning everyone has the same amount of money.
We'll include property,
the same amount of wealth.
Then what happens as the game progresses and really as a function of chance,
I mean I know yet we have to use your head a little bit and monopoly,
but the basic rule is just buy everything you can get your hands on
and then trade meanly,
something like that.
So at the beginning everybody has the same amount and then as you begin to play,
if you had enough players you would develop an a normal distribution because
some people would win relatively consistently and some people would lose
relatively consistently.
And so the money starts to be distributed in a normal distribution.
But the thing about money and the thing about lots of things is that
zero is involved in zero is a weird place because if you're playing a trading
game and you hit zero,
then you're done.
And so,
and it's very hard to recover from zero and you know it's really hard to
recover.
You know when you're doomed in monopoly,
you know,
you can tell you've got some resources,
but there's going to be some crisis when you land on some hotel and you're going
to get wiped out,
you know it.
So there's a point at which you're headed for zero.
Even if you have something you know and you might be rescued by
luck,
but you know when you're doomed.
So what happens is that as you continue to play monopoly more and more people
stack up at zero and fewer and fewer people have more and more money.
And when the game is over,
everyone has nothing except one person and they have all of it.
Now the funny thing about that is that in some sense that's how trading games
work.
You know,
you got,
you might wonder why is that?
Why there is inequality in a society and it's easy to consider that it's because
the society is corrupt and perhaps,
you know,
society's ours somewhat or horribly corrupt.
That's the variation.
There's no society that's without its criminal criminal element and fixed
element anyways.
Trading Games tend to produce a Prieto distribution so that very many people
have very little and a tiny minority have a tremendous amount.
That's the 1% that you hear about.
Right?
And you know the thing about that 1% is that that's happened in every society
that's ever been studied.
It doesn't really matter what the governmental system is and it certainly
handled it certainly happened under the Soviets,
that's for sure.
And there was a lot of people who had enough zero so they just died.
So you know,
the,
the Utopian dream was completely unimplementable for a variety of very complex
reasons.
One is that it's very hard to fight against that distribution pattern when
people are trading.
Because mere statistics,
we'll do that.
And then there's other things that,
and I should tell you as well,
that the Prieto distribution that governs a lot of things.
So
if you look at books,
if I remember properly last year there was something like a million English
language books published
and I think 500 of them sold more than a hundred thousand copies,
which is none,
right?
That's none.
And of that 500 you can be sure that one of them was by Stephen King and he took
half the money because there's like five authors in the English language who are
on every airport paperback stand,
occupying the top rung.
And that's massive real estate,
right?
Cause it's replicated everywhere.
And because there are so prominent and because there are no names when people
are in a hurry and they just want something to read,
they just grabbed that and then more money goes to those people.
And so,
you know,
success breeds success and failure breeds failure.
And it's not necessarily linear.
And that's a really difficult thing to deal with.